[Applause]
before we welcome Tekken 8 next year
here are the seven greatest moments that
made Tekken 7 such a great
[Applause]
game ranchu winning the Tekken World
Tour 2018 using Panda impressive player
dude this is amazing the low the low
with it due to the
he has a the wall the wall cork screw OK
Kazumi oh the block don't punish oh 7
seconds left on the clock canny kill oh
what was that a miss and that's the
thing all he has to do is tap down back
and he could end kdans his tournament oh
man look at this kudan has hardly any
life left oh it's guaranteed last hit
bear
Champion oh oh he got him over 15
seconds oh he hit heav other side be
careful one more he can end it here Q
Dan we have a animal of a champion
[Music]
here Lil imagins performance in Evo
Tekken
7 oh muscle Buster nice
break over the rep the
wall you better
get is enough ma more pressure what's he
going to do now yes pedal kick counter
hit on that he interrupts and he gets
another counter hit counter hit push
guaranteed follow
upin oh my god oh he it he still gets oh
yeah this is going to be juicy yeah he
was able to confirm it as well oh my God
that was so close the throw break Majin
is so sharp oh M the tra again he gets
it and he's play he broke
it jdcr oh he gets it one more hit can
do it oh my the he
it AIS I can't believe what I'm seeing
can I guys can I get a break any chance
I know we wanted to take a break later
sta any chance we could get a gurnie
kajim maru's comeback in master up
nine tearing the ankles up tearing the
ankles up watch out though he's
R the CR theow again kick destroying the
ankles shoulders C my
god let's
go oh one
[Applause]
more both plays in range another one oh
oh my God oh my dead he's hella
dead get ready to fly one more round
right now buff Jo buff her uh uh uh on
his wall uhuh get on this wall is going
crazy you guys can hear him I have
nothing to say the momentum ship I've
never seen the momentum sh a perfect a
perfect KAG Maru just one master c n
with jie with
jie the worst possible
PA Akuma taking over Tekken
tournaments second round number two Pok
oh my God he went for the running two
and got long for it at this tiny pixel
with the rard here would do so much
damage but he doesn't use the rard he's
going to get a combo instead go for the
into the demon and that was very that
was very much something I've seen
oh is that going to hit he's doing a
move armor Son
Goku is this going to be dead though I
don't think so one pixel a pixel oh R
avable the jump oh my God oh my God thre
are almost there put gets the confirm
and that's going to be oh it's party
time and Chin's invited oh here it is oh
here we go here we go why did you say
that Mark I I wanted
oh my God look at the help the demon the
demon let's go I can't believe what
we're seeing here look at the life bar
oh my goodness he probably has a sliver
right he might have a
sver oh my God oh my let's
go arsel Ash being a four-time Evo
Champion my God the tension here Paul's
such a hard- heating character here you
got to be ready arson try to close out
the tournament but he's pushing him
towards the danger zone oh back red
again he's a phoenix ahead he's a
phoenix
behind AR's going to get the tournament
arand he's your Evo Japan Champion 15
seconds on the clock AR to Twin the evil
tournament
second and aren Edge is your evil 2019
Champion ladies and
gentlemen
unbelievable the wall everything's
hitting mid low mid forward to punish
again 1 2 3 into mix that could have
been in on the dot and arson Ash is
going to be your Evolution
2023 Japan winner two it he takes it
conversion conversion one hit one hit
will do it and arson X surviv the Rain
Drive attempt it seem never but there it
is arson X is your Tek seven champion at
Evo
2023 yet again four times count four
times two in Japan baby two in Vegas
Four Evo titles hit him with a four wow
think SE that one here Evo before
unbelievable absolutely unbelievable the
P the Battle of the Gods between me and
jdcr fig toer there what's going to
happen oh he didn't time match he didn't
even get off of me dude stop it
oh he might be able to get a race drive
here oh oh he drops it back though get
him do that again oh what a block oh
step four is he dead oh first three now
what's he going to do he does have
rage oh wow my email
broke oh gets the big Lun and he's going
to close it out two rounds for one
what's he going to do there's no time
left
oh good
block there's no side left oh my godness
God that's why that's why the ven death
grip hits you that's why I hurt so bad
too this going to be do a lot of damage
oh what's he going to do
oh no
time oh my God oh my
[Applause]
[Music]
God yes
yes yes Ken's Road to
[Music]
Glory so close the
missed that's not what you want to
happen not jump this is an
our oh the rard is that going to do it
oh he killed them what the I can't
believe it I can't my God and he hugs KN
right afterwards cannot believe my eyes
the next comeback let me see this real
quick
oh what a
legend oh my god did you see that oh man
what the oh you two Z fishing for that
down for two no time what's he going to
do time hey you you're going to think
he's going to have to go low there's no
time left oh snap that's not are you
serious
oh my God K is crazy my
God high things up oh not the the rage
oh oh this this one does so much damage
so huge so huge oh the
wall oh he got it he got
it C is your Global champion and the
Torso touch the
celebration
we're looking forward to next year as we
know that there will be a lot of great
moments like these in Tekken 8 but
before that we just wanted to say thank
you to Tekken
[Music]